est-ce que ça fait déjà un mois et demi
oui ça fait déjà un mois et demi non
vous avez compris aujourd'hui c'est le
jour de ma treizième séances de
détatouage au laser je file il pleut
c'est génial donc vous venez avec moi
on revient et on discute comme
d'habitude à l'ego
[Musique]
il
petit contretemps faux départ en fait je
me suis allé au centre on m'a mis la
promenade et seyante j'ai attendu une
heure et à l'heure où c'était mon tour
de passer malheureusement le laser est
tombé en panne
donc ils le font réparer il me rappelle
pour me redonner un rendez vous dès que
ces prêts ça y est le laser est réparé
j'ai réussi à avoir un nouveau rendez
vous une petite dizaine de jours est
passé et donc je retrouve
quelques jours on a aussi perdu quelques
de dréan en même temps du coup c'est
raccord que pour elle le tue et comme si
le thème de la journée justement
non
voilà c'est fini la treizième séances de
détatouage est terminée la sixième avec
le pic autour
aujourd'hui tu veux vous dire de
particulier en termes de réglages de la
machine on est resté un petit peu sur le
même style que la fois précédente
c'est à dire des réglages qui se
rapproche un petit peu de l'ancienne
méthode c'est à dire le cul switch mais
encore bon quand même avec la détendre
impulsion un peu plus court comme le
permet le pic au chaud ce qui veut dire
deux choses d'abord ça de nouveau fait
un petit peu mal un petit peu plus malin
parce que comme vous vous souvenez
l'ancienne méthode était plus
douloureuse la l'avantagent c'est que
j'ai la pommade anesthésiante je vous le
dis à chaque fois mais vraiment c'est
une bénédiction pour moi donc beaucoup
moins douloureux qu avant mais quand
même un petit peu plus que les premières
séances de pick au jour à l'oreille
si vous tendez l'oreille sur la sur la
séance que j'ai eue là on entend les
petits crépitements qui sont le signe
que
encre explose donc bah comme ça au bios
mais il reste de lancre a explosé ça
c'est la mauvaise nouvelle la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'elle explose donc ça
ça continue ça continue à fonctionner
mais ça on en reparlera à la fin de la
vidéo
une autre conséquence du fait de
contrats proche des réglages d'avancé
que autant les premières séances depuis
cauchoise étaient espacées d'un mois les
deux dernières là ont été espacées d'un
mois et demi un petit peu plus même avec
ce petit contretemps de pannes de
machines là je n'y retourne que dans
deux mois
donc dans deux mois ça veut dire en 2019
mais ça veut dire surtout que on va
rater l'anniversaire de cyril puisque il
va fêter ses deux ans le 2 décembre
donc ben on va rater ça je comprendrais
bien que jules endroit où il est placé
je vais pas lui faire souffler ses
bougies
parce que ce serait dangereux si c'est
bon elle est d'accord on lui fait
souffler ses bougies
vous êtes un peu déçu vous attendiez un
truc un peu plus ah ouais bon on va
rester on va rester soft ensuite avant
de passer à un comparatif entre les deux
les deux dernières séances
conçu à rêver au centre et donc absente
de médecine de médecine esthétique qui
fait donc pas que du des tatouages
je suis tombé sur une pub d'épilation au
laser et je me suis dit mais à temps et
si je me passe du laser sur la fesse
pour me faire détatouer est-ce que ça va
aussi m'épiler la fesse parce que après
tout la question peut se poser
alors je vais poser la question la
réponse est non la réponse est non
pourquoi parce que c'est pas les mêmes
alors c'est pas les mêmes machines et
puis c'est pas les mêmes réglages non
plus
pour un détatouage et pour une épilation
définitive au laser donc alors ça
n'empêche pas que ça crame les poils en
surface quand on se fait des tatoués
mais ça ne craint pas le bulbe donc ça
veut dire que les poils repoussent
toutefois au delà de m'avoir rassurer
modérément ce que j'étais un peu inquiet
a quand même sur le fait que je vais
garder des poils aux fesses j'y tiens un
coûteux que si hollywood hills ça me
permet surtout de vous donner un petit
conseil si vous envisagez d'aller vous
faire des théâtres et au laser rasé vous
avant braz et vous la zone parce que la
bonne nouvelle c'est que si vous faites
des tatous une zone qui est poilu vous
allez pas vous retrouver avec la zone où
sans poil à la fin mais le truc à savoir
c'est que par contre s'il ya beaucoup de
poils sur le passage ça bouffe un peu de
l'énergie du laser c'est à dire que le
l'énergie que le laser mais a cramé vos
poils c'est autant d'énergie en moins
qui arrive jusqu'à lancre donc c'est de
l'efficacité de perdus donc si vous
faites des tatoués une zone fois lui
raser à mondiale est comme ça ça vous
gagnerez en efficacité
c'est mon petit type écouter voilà
maintenant bon je sais pourquoi vous
êtes tous là on va faire le petit
comparatif rituel entre les deux les
deux dernières séances pour voir où on
en est après deux ans d'anniversaire du
tatouage qui veut pas dire deux ans de
détatouage les deux ans du des tatouages
ce sera au début 2019
à peu près au moment de la prochaine
séance d'ailleurs du coup voilà à quoi
ressemblait le tatouage juste avant la
dernière séance il ya un mois et demi
et voilà à quoi ressemble mon tatouage
juste avant la séance d'aujourd'hui
donc je ne sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais moi et encore une fois je
trouve que les photos en a peu hommage
aux progrès mais je trouve que ça
progresse dans le bras long dans le bon
sens le médecin m'a confirmé aussi bon
il est toujours un petit peu embêté
parce que il dit
c'est quand même long voilà surtout pour
quelqu'un qui a eu cette séance de pick
au chu de que switch avant mais on est
tous d'accord pour dire que depuis deux
séances la à peu près ça progresse on
est dans le on est dans le bon chemin
si vous regardez bien il ya des petits
endroits là là là par exemple où les
traits ont vraiment beaucoup disparu il
ya toujours les yeux on est repassés sur
les yeux aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on les
avait laissés au repos parce que la peau
avait vraiment été très abîmée par les
premières séances avec le premier laser
là il a estimé que c'était suffisamment
cicatrisée pour pouvoir repasser dessus
donc il ya quand même des endroits où ça
disparaît nettement tout le reste
pâlit vraiment de séance en séance la
depuis depuis les deux dernières donc je
suis soulagé je suis assez content on
n'est pas au bout du chemin pour autant
parce que ça reste quand même assez
assez apparent j'ai demandé au médecin
aussi qu'ils pensaient pouvoir me donner
une petite estimation du nombre de
séances qui restait selon lui c'est
assez classique que ça aille plus vite
sur la fin du processus c'est à dire sur
les dernières séances sont généralement
ça s'accélère
ça va plus vite ce qui est assez logique
puisqu'il reste moins d'encre donc c'est
plus visible à l'oeil nu donc bon chat
échaudé craint l'eau froide
il n'a pas voulu trop se mouiller parce
que voilà il m'avait annoncé 4 au début
là on est à la 6e il en faut encore
quelques-unes c'est difficile en fait de
faire une prédiction basculerait savoir
vraiment la quantité d'encre qui reste
et donc c'est compliqué mais quand même
il m'a dit si on veut être optimiste on
peut dire qu'ils restent trois séances
et après on en parle plus alors trois
séances si on va sur les réglages là ça
fait quand même encore six mois puisque
en l'espace de deux mois maintenant
parce que comme il m'a dit avec ce type
de réglages il faut laisser les faits ce
faire les faits ce faire les faits
c'est la blague du médecin mais j'aime
ça j'aime bien donc donc estimation
optimiste encore 3 séances encore six
mois ce qui nous amènera gentiment aux
beaux jours à l'été donc vous n'avez pas
fini de voir mes fesses vous allez les
voir souvent mes années voilà petit truc
il ya des personnes du centre
saint-honoré ponctué d'un coup je vais
faire mes séances de détatouage qui
m'ont dit qu'il ya eu des abonnés qui
sont venus se faire détatouer chez eux
si vous faites partie de ces gens là ça
m'intéresse que vous m'envoyez un petit
message vous allez réussir à me trouver
sans trop de problème je pense envoyez
moi un petit message pour me dire
comment ça se passe pour vous est ce que
ça fonctionne
qui vous a des photos c'est cool
d'ailleurs même si vous n'êtes pas dans
ce centre là mais si vous avez entrepris
des tatouages
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un petit un
petit message ça m'intéresse on pourra
faire une petite petite comparaison
comme ça ce sera ce sera intéressant
voilà écouter qu'est ce qu'il me reste à
vous dire mais il me reste à vous dire
que donc pour cyril je vais pas faire
une fête d'anniversaire mais bon pensez
à lui le 2 décembre ce sera ce sera
assez deux ans en attendant on va
écouter les vidéos continuer évidemment
donc je vous donne rendez vous très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos et d'ici là
mettez vous bien et surtout portes et
volets
[Musique]